una luz de esperanza para los presos
políticos en mianmar los familiares
esperan la liberación de más de 800 de
ellos
mi hijo fue detenido el 14 de septiembre
de 2021 y llego a la cárcel a finales de
octubre
fue condenado a 3 años de prisión por
incitación contra los militares no sé si
será liberado hoy o no
los indultados son en su mayoría los
presos de las cárceles del centro
comercial de rangún el anuncio de la
amnistía fue hecho por el líder militar
de la junta minga online que se tomó el
poder en un golpe de estado en febrero
de 2021 al acusar de fraude al partido
ganador de las elecciones de la líder
aún sang-soo si ella quien fue arrestada
desde el día del golpe el primero de
febrero de 2021 no figura entre los
liberados aún se desconoce si el
australiano john turner asesor de la
depuesta líder será excarcelado el
autoproclamado primer ministro aprovechó
la celebración del día de la unión del
país para defender las actuaciones del
ejército
todos sabemos que uno intento de cometer
fraude las elecciones de noviembre de
el ejército les instó a resolver estas
cuestiones inapropiadas pero lo
ignoraron así que declaró el estado de
emergencia y el ejército estaba
asumiendo la responsabilidad del estado
villar al hombre que iba a llevar la
represión militar contra los
manifestantes que salieron de forma
masiva para protestar contra los
militares ha dejado unos 1.500 civiles
muertos según datos de la oficina de
derechos humanos de la onu la junta
liberó a unos 23.000 presos el pasado
mes de abril